you know Howard came and read here about
a year and a half ago for us and not
long after he read I picked up a book
called world beware about the the
current state of American politics
written by a man who coined the phrase
counterculture and I found out that he
couldn't find a single publisher in the
United States to pick up his book there
was not anyone who would touch it I
think people get the impression that as
long as books like if I did it by OJ
Simpson can get published anything can
get published and it's not the case so
tonight we're here to celebrate
something very very fortunate that books
like this can be published a power
governments cannot suppress can be
published by amazing presses like city
lights and we can hear the voice
directly of some of the greatest
statesmen living in the United States
today some of the greatest intellectuals
and I'm proud to introduce one of them
now please welcome Howard Zinn
thank you
thank you thank you Alex thank you
whoever you are who applauded if you
didn't applaud thanks anyway
alex is from back pages books right here
on moody Street in Waltham and they're
responsible for this and want to thank
them they're struggling
hope you doesn't mind my saying this but
they are they're struggling little
bookstore and they need support like all
struggling little bookstores and you
know I think that we need to direct
people more to bookstores and to
libraries away from television away from
the newspapers I say away from
television even though I know there's a
television camera focused on us right
now question is will they turn us off as
a result of this now this is this is
different this is this is special and so
a lot of this book a power that
governments could not suppress a man
named Greg Ruggiero decided on this book
I didn't really write the book I wrote
the stuff that's in it and he put it
together that is it there's a bunch of
essay it's a bunch of essays that I've
done over the last three or four years
many of them for the progressive
magazine some of them here and there I
did an essay on Thoreau for Princeton
University Press I and didn't you know
essay on Eugene Debs those two go
together don't they yeah and a kind of
socialist anarchist I haven't done
anything on any Republican that I know
of but I anyway you'll find all sorts of
things in this book things that even
surprised me when I find it's there so
but the basic idea of the book I don't
read you know they always talk about
these things as
he's going to do a reading I never read
from my books ah I don't think they're
worth it I I mean I'll read from Tolstoy
a thorough a Mark Twain I thought no I
read from my you know then you're stuck
with it whereas if you pick up a book
and you you read something of mine
you can immediately put it down if you
like and go on to something else so I
won't read from a book but I'll try to
tell you something about what's in it or
at least you know what is suggested by
this book fundamentally the book tries
to make a connection between history and
what is going on today I'm that's always
been my attitude as a historian right
evan has never been interested in just
doing history to go into the archives
and look up these old letters and
documents it's it's interesting of
course it's fun but no I that's not the
kind of history I I wanted to do I
wanted to go into history and come out
into the present I want to make a
connection between something that
happened in the past because I want a
history - to help us in dealing with the
situation we face today and we're always
facing a situation today especially
today especially now especially now with
an administration that has taken us into
two wars in a few years with an
administration that has run amok with
power that has attacked the
constitutional rights of people all over
this country administration is wasted
the enormous wealth that this country
has on war and are funneling this wealth
into the upper richest 1% of the
population an administration that has
taken power unto itself and will not
listen to anything that anybody says
except maybe four or five people around
president so we're in a situation now
where we I think desperately need to
learn something from history because I
feel that if
people of the United States at that
moment when George Bush got up before
the microphone and and said you know we
must go to war 9/11 took place terrorist
act took place and therefore we must go
to war against Afghanistan well if
people listening knew history they would
not immediately rush as most Americans
did at that point eighty percent of
Americans rush to say yes yes Congress
of course rushed to say yes because
that's the job of Congress to say yes
whenever the president wants to go to
war and because people do some history
there would not be that rush to support
a war there would not be that that
acceptance of the idea oh we're going to
war to fight terrorism there would not
be an acceptance of the idea where we're
going to what to bring democracy to Iraq
bring democracy to the whole Middle East
because of people knew some history they
would know of all those instances in the
American past when presidents have come
before the public and said well as
President Polk did in 1846 we've got to
go into Mexico to spread civilization to
the Mexicans or as McKinley did in 1898
oh we've got to go to Cuba to liberate
the Cubans we're always liberating
somebody but we went into Cuban we
liberated a few in fact we did we
liberated the Cubans from Spain but not
from us and that's our record our record
is is sometimes liberating people from
other tyrants and then imposing our will
on them so the Spanish were out of Cuba
in 1898 and American corporations and
American military or in Cuba and stay
there for a very long time dictatorship
after dictatorship
after dictatorship supported by the
United States the people knew some of
that history if they knew the history of
the American occupation of the
Philippines they would be very wary of
an American occupation of Iraq they'd be
very wary of the idea oh we're occupying
Iraq so that we can bring democracy to
Iraq
we fought a bloody war in the
Philippines we committed massacres in
the Philippines and then we occupy the
Philippine Islands for 50 years and did
we bring democracy to the Philippines we
brought dictatorship after dictatorship
and misery to the Filipino people about
a half a million of whom had died in the
war that we waged against the Filipinos
and of course the history then into the
20th century into the the Marines going
again again into the Caribbean General
Smedley Butler advise you to look
general Smedley Butler up a Marine
general who who won two congressional
medals of Honor leading the military
into various countries in Central
America and at a certain point he
stopped and turned around and said you
know I was an errand boy for Wall Street
he realized that what he had done what
the American military had done in
Central America was to try to make
Central America the various countries in
Central America in the Caribbean in
Haiti and the Dominican Republic in
Nicaragua and Honduras to make them
profitable places for American
corporations not places where democracy
would flourish in fact democracy did not
flourish in all of those places we we
swear we sent the Marines to take over
and to do the bidding of American
economic interest and of course bringing
the history up for two more recent time
if people even studied closely the
history of the Vietnam War that wasn't
that long ago was it there are actually
people here who remember the Vietnam War
despite the attempts of the media to
forget the Vietnam War despite the
attempts of our political leaders you
know when we when we went into Iraq the
first time in 1991 and and won this
quick smashing victory a splendid little
war just like the spanish-american war
very quick victorious war and
uh and George Bush said senior that's a
smarter one the way George Bush said
Georgia senior said well we have now
buried the Vietnam syndrome in the sands
of the Arabian Peninsula rare poetic
statement out of the White House but
well the fact is we have not buried the
Vietnam syndrome Vietnam is coming back
to haunt us
and people are thinking about that more
and more every day and people remembered
Vietnam they would remember how the
calls for withdrawal that came early on
I must say in 1967 two years after we
were escalating the war in 1967 I wrote
a book I love to advertise my books I'll
try to resist it later on but I can't
resist this one in 1967 I wrote a book
called Vietnam the logic of withdrawal
and wine was I must say the first book
they've done a number of books on on the
war in Vietnam and mine was the first
book that called simply for the United
States to get out not equivocating not
setting timetables not saying we'll get
out if and when we're not going to go to
Paris and negotiate for five years or
six years we just had to get out ah and
and the arguments against that at that
time were the same as the arguments
today when people say as I say and as a
number of people have said as
congressman Murtha
a Vietnam veteran said right said no we
must just leave we don't belong there
it's not our country get out of there
let the Iraqis determine their own
destiny as difficult as it will be but
we are making it more difficult by our
occupation and the arguments then were
the same well we can't do that there'll
be chaos
we can
we chaos in Vietnam we there was chaos
in Vietnam we were bombing Vietnam into
eternity we were we were destroying
Vietnamese villages we were destroying
their land we were killing their people
ultimately 2 million people died in
Vietnam and we mustn't leave because
there'll be chaos in Vietnam so we
stayed we didn't leave in 1967 when a
few of us are calling through withdrawal
we stayed and what was a resolve another
30,000 American dead another million
Vietnamese dead and so the same
arguments today Brazil we mustn't
believe Iraq as if our presence in Iraq
is preventing civil war question is is
our presence preventing civil war or is
our presence provoking civil war and I
think they the answer is clear just
looking at a history of these four years
of our occupation in Iraqi rock is a
mess after four years and the numbers
the numbers of Iraqi dead and wounded
are enormous into the hundreds of
thousands
so yes the history is useful and and not
the history that you get in the
traditional textbooks but the history
that a citizen learns for himself or
herself when a citizen goes to the
library mr. citizen listens to the
independent media when a citizen reads
alternative journals instead of simply
you know watching CNN you know and Fox
News so yes history is very useful it
still is today and and I think that one
of the things we might learn from
history and this is very very important
very important conclusion to get from
the long history of this country is that
the government's interests are not
necessarily same as ours
in fact I rarely the same as hours
because if you think the government's
interests are the same as yours then you
think well if something is going wrong
it must be that they made a mistake
because they really care about us they
don't care about us the government does
not care about its own soldiers if it
did it would not Excel submit soldiers
into the Quagmire's of Vietnam in Iraq
it would not send them into a situation
where they're going to come back maimed
or without arms or legs or they'd come
back with their psyche destroyed they
really cared about the soldiers and
cared about the families of the soldiers
it would not be taking them the wealth
of this country and squandering it on
five hundred billion dollars this year
on a military budget that's a hard thing
to grasp that the government does not
have the same interests as ours it's
hard to grasp because we grow up in a
culture where the language of the
culture predisposes us to think yes we
have a common interest that the
Constitution starts off in a preamble we
the people of the United States you know
establishes it wasn't we the people who
establish the Constitution was 55 rich
white men who established the
Constitution I know you're not supposed
to say anything about the founding
fathers
they're our fathers we're all one family
not so the founding fathers were
slaveholders and merchants and
bondholders really and sure they set up
a government that was more democratic
than other governments of the world they
set up a government that was independent
of England but did not set up a
government there was a government of the
people they set up a slave holding
government that was going to do the
interests of the bondholders and the
merchants the interests of the
government and the interests of the
people right from the beginning were not
the same and that same difference of
interest has continued down to the
present day all through the look at the
history of legislation in this country
its class legislation its legislation
that
always benefited the upper classes
there's always been subsidies for the
corporations and subsidies for the
railroads they didn't call a welfare
when when a government began helping
poor people they called it welfare when
the government gave hundreds of millions
of acres of land to the railroads they
didn't call that welfare but the
legislative history of this country is a
history of legislation favoring the rich
to put it bluntly and there was some
breakthroughs there's some oddities
there was some moments in history when
this was not true
in the 1930s something happened in the
1960s something happened what happened
is that people rose up all over the
country and demanded change and the
demands grew so loud and and so
threatening that then in the 1930s we
got Social Security and we got
unemployment insurance and we got
subsidized housing and the 60s we got
Medicare and Medicaid so there have been
moments in our history when the people
and their desires and their anguish over
the situation has broken through and
then then we got legislation that moved
away from the traditional class upper
class legislation of the government but
it is extremely important to understand
this conflict of interest between
government and us otherwise you will
think and the young guy going off the
wall with a well Bush's interest is the
same as mine it's not North Exxon's
interests the same as mine nor
halliburton's interests the same as mine
no that's a very important thing to
learn I think from from history and and
when you learn when you study the
history of the United States you do not
see the kind of country that we all
learn about when we go to school which
is a kind of exaltation of America we're
not different by the way than other
countries countries everywhere teach
their history in a nationalist way now
they're all
I'd full of their flag in their anthem
and you know their history and the
United States is no different except
we're bigger and better and stronger but
but but we are and we grow up in this
country singing the star-spangled banner
you know liberty and justice for
pledging allegiance and all that we grow
up the idea that we are special we are
different we we are the Boy Scouts of
the world you know we help countries
across the street you know we we we yeah
we just we good we have our little
problems like slavery maybe maybe we
weren't nice to the Native Americans and
yeah we have our little problems but
basically we're okay well when you look
at the history of this country we were
not we were not we destroyed Indian
civilizations we expanded into the
Caribbean we expanded at the Pacific we
sent our young people to worry again and
again we did not take care of poor
people when poor people organized and
when workers were organized into unions
and without unstriped the government
called out the police and the National
Guard in the army to suppress their
strikes that's the history of labor
struggles in this country so it's not
that it's not the kind of glorifying
history that too many of us you know
grew up with and when I say that and
when anybody says something like that
there's a kind of fear of saying it
you're putting down our country you've
you're an patriotic no I'm not putting
down our country when I am honest about
what our government has done I'm putting
down our government yes but there's a
distinction between the government and
the country it's a very fundamental
principle of democracy that the
government and the country are not the
same the government and the people are
not the same that's the basic idea the
independence which says governments are
set up by the people there artificial
creations they're set up to achieve
certain ends the right to life and
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
equality and when governments become
destructive of those ends according to
the words of the Declaration of
Independence it is the right of the
people to alter or abolish the
government that's serious
those are revolutionary words but after
all it was a revolution and as something
about a revolution it brings out some
honesty and also brings out their the
idealistic language and and hopes and
dreams which may not be realized because
no the dream of the Declaration of
indepen swill not realize but it's there
it's telling us that governments are not
to be obeyed simply because their
governments to be patriotic is not to
simply do what the government says to be
patriotic is to subscribe to the
principles of the Declaration of
Independence to check up on the
government to see if it really is
fulfilling its obligation to take care
of our right to equality to life and
liberty and the pursuit of happiness and
patriotism in the best sense of the term
means following those principles and
when the government doesn't follow those
principles the government is being
unpatriotic so we must be honest about
ourselves about our history about the
history of our government and I think
that we need maybe we need some
confession on the part of our government
leaders an acknowledgement you know like
an Alcoholics Anonymous where they get
up
get up before you know and and confess
yeah maybe maybe you know Cheney and
Bush and the other should get up you
know you know form a group called
imperialists Anonymous ah and and tell
the truth and that is what did what they
are aiming for the Middle East is not
democracy and not Liberty and they don't
really care about the overthrow of
tyrants like Saddam Hussein our
government has supported tyrants all
over the world know what they really
care about it's hard to say this isn't
it oil
it seems so mean so cheap although the
oil won't be cheap but but it seems you
know really it's just oil yes it's oil
history comes in handy their history of
American policy towards the Middle East
has been based on the desire to control
the oil resources of the Middle East
that's been true ever since the end of
World War two ever since President
Roosevelt got together with even Saud of
Saudi Arabia and they made a deal United
States will replace the the old oil
powers the Dutch and the British and
French in the Middle East and in return
the United States will support the even
Saud government talk about democracy
live in South government the Saudi
government government of Saudi Arabia
all these years has been as far from
democracy as you can find
but we did not invade Saudi Arabia to
give democracy to Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia gives us oil and is our ally in
our quest for oil and in the Middle East
so yes history is very useful you know
in all of these ways and I guess a
problem is once we accept what the
reality is once we look honestly at what
we have done and what we're doing and
the question is you know what do we do
about it and now we helpless to do
anything about it because that's I think
that's a great problem that people even
when they oppose the government feel
helpless to do
thing about it and and and so we we
don't see we don't see today although
most Americans today are opposed to the
war and most Americans today are opposed
to the bush policies we don't see a
connection between that opposition and
any kind of change in policy we don't
see the wishes of the people represented
in what the government does we are not
seeing the kind of actions that took
place during the Vietnam War with a
passive opposition to the war it became
more than passive when it became civil
disobedience we're seeing the beginnings
of that with soldiers who are refusing
to go back to Iraq we are you seen the
beginnings of that with the families of
soldiers saying that we are opposed to
this war but the fact is we do not have
democracy in foreign policy ah that's
that's a very important thing to
acknowledge because we're always talking
about bringing democracy everywhere
everywhere else we do not have democracy
in this country when it comes to foreign
policy
oh we learn in school we have three
branches of government and we have
checks and balances and the legislature
will check the you know executive and
the Supreme Court will see if things
that constitutional or not that doesn't
work in foreign policy the president
decides on war and Congress goes along
like a bunch of sheep really that's what
they did in the Mexican War that's what
it in a special barrack and well that's
we did in World War one that's what he
did in the Vietnam War
you know the Gulf of Tonkin Resolution
did members of Congress know where the
Gulf of Tonkin was when they voted for
the Gulf of Tonkin Resolution did they
know what happened in the Gulf of Tonkin
turned out to be a mess of lies but he
immediately voted to give lyndon johnson
the authority to launch what then became
a very long war in vietnam that there's
no no democracy in matters of foreign
policy and no checks and balances
no hope that Congress will will stop and
say hey let's look into this let's see
if this is true and then no and no hope
for the Supreme Court deciding that a
war is unconstitutional and we have not
fought a constitutional war since the
end of World War two Constitution
requires that Congress declare war
Congress has not declared war in any war
that we have fought of the many since
World War two well you learn in school
if something is unconstitutional is a
job of the Supreme Court's to say so and
do something about it no after all so
who are the Supreme Court just because
they wear black robes doesn't give them
any special moral standing they are
political appointees and they do the
bidding of the people who appointed them
so if they don't have democracy in the
upper reaches of government that we
can't depend on checks and balances on
representative government that well
obviously I think leads us to the
thought that if we're going to have
democracy it depends on us depends on
the people and historically that's been
the situation historically when when
working people found out that the
government is not going to do anything
about the 12-hour day they organized
they were not on strike and they won
they won the eight-hour a day when black
people in South sought at the government
not just the state governments but the
national government was not going to do
anything about racial segregation or
brutality in the south then black people
organized they demonstrated they went to
prison they were beaten some of them
were killed but he created a national
commotion which finally brought
democracy alive and that's a situation
we're in today we need to bring
democracy alive today and it requires
the actions of ordinary people and we
mustn't despair about the fact that the
government has all the power the
government has the FBI they have all
this secret apparatus they are
watching us I don't think I'm paranoid
they really are watching us and they
they love that so so our job is to watch
them and and we have to understand that
despite all the trappings of government
which indicate that they are all
powerful they have the military they
have the money they have the the the
security apparatus and so on a fact is
historically and here's where history
comes in handy the most powerful
governments have had to change policy
when the people demanded it when an
outcry grew so great when the pressure
from below grows so great that it became
threatening to the government and the
government had to change policy we have
seen government's toppled we have seen
tyrannies toppled all over the world
that seemed to be impregnable you know
in the Philippines suddenly a
dictatorship Marcos is totally in charge
he wakes up one morning and a million
people in the streets he leaves really
this has happened in place after place
in Haiti Duvalier jumps on a plane quick
get out of here the people are rising up
the fact is governments like all
powerful entities are vulnerable the
government needs people to obey it in
order to keep power when people stop
obeying the government Lucy loses its
power corporations need people to work
for it when people stop working for
corporations then the corporation's
helpless we saw this in the 1930s
General Motors and Ford huge
corporations we're not gonna have a
union here but when the workers left the
factories or even when they sat in and
the factories and Woodill that wouldn't
let production go on General Motors was
helpless and so it's important to keep
in mind that the power of the
establishment rests on our obedience
when we start disobeying and that's
where Thoreau comes in and that's where
that's where the great people in our
history
and that's where Helen Keller comes in
and Emma Goldman comes in and Mark Twain
comes in and Eugene Debs and fannie lou
hamer and Martin Luther King that's
where they come in and when that happens
then something something will change and
our job is to participate did not
process it at this point to to light a
fire under these wishy-washy Democrats
who have just won an election and who
are sort of falling back timidly they
want to pass non-binding resolutions how
about a binding resolution how about yes
you know how about how about holding
hearings on impeachment impeachment
impeachment I'm talking about a double
impeach bush in Cheney because you know
they go together and no impeachment is
not a radical solution some people acted
Oh impeachment they tremble at the
thought of impeachment some people up
you know that in the high reaches of the
Democratic Party oh we mustn't talk
about impeach appeasement is a
constitutional measure it's right there
in the Constitution the president may be
impeached for high crimes and
misdemeanors what Bush has done does not
matter does that not match the
requirement of high crimes and
misdemeanors the sending us into war
lying to us taking away our liberties
taking away the lives of thousands of
Americans and and and subjecting so many
of them to mutilation and and a terrible
future doesn't that does that not meet
the requirement of high crimes we have
to talk to our congressman or Congress
women we have to talk to them but let
them know how we feel we have to beef
them up and stiffen their spine and tell
them they get going because it's a
situation that cannot be tolerated for
too long
and I have to stop soon because I have
to give you a chance
and although the you know the Orthodox
definition free speech is that the
speaker speaks for 50 minutes and gives
the audience five minutes a freedom of
speech freedom speech means you know the
president can speak to fourteen thirty
million people I can speak to a few
hundred it's a free country and keep
this in mind about power and keep in
mind about when the government says
woman [ __ ] says oh we we will not
retreat we will not give in we will stay
of course no matter why oh they asked
them what about the people what about
the the fact that most people are
opposed to this well that doesn't bother
me well we've seen that in history we've
seen people say oh I will never yield I
will never give him and they gave in
when enough people got together with
enough people organized they they gave
and we've seen that again and again haha
I remember George Wallace getting up
before proud of his southern supporters
are and saying segregation now
segregation tomorrow segregation forever
and wild applause two years later the
segregation signs were down in the south
and Wallace was campaigning in the black
neighborhoods for support in this
presidential race things change things
change it's up to us to move that change
along it's up to us to bring democracy
alive thank
thank you
we're going to take questions for about
a half an hour there are two microphones
up here if you can line up in the side
aisles if you have a question and we'll
just go back and forth between the
microphones starting with this one and
then to that one and go for a half an
hour and then we'll do book signings so
if you have questions feel free to come
on up to the ops
my son okay as you know I came from
Nashville Ohio just ask you this
question so I'm trying make it good and
I took off the Yankees hat so being a
community organizer and a student
citizen I just was asking for some
advice as far as how do we stem the tide
of cynicism and apathy you know to keep
that from reaching the levees of the
optimism that you exude and other
politicians or people like myself or
other people who really care about
things that's going on you know how do
we stem the tide of cynicism and
pessimism and hopelessness and all the
things that all of us feel on Tuesday
and Thursday and Saturday and I I think
that I think the key to that is well
they're two keys to that I think one is
history one is one was going back and
pointing to those times in the past when
people have helped felt hopeless and
people have felt that they couldn't do
anything but they acted anyway and they
acted and acted and acted and then
something happened I mean that's what
happened I lived in the south for seven
years during the years of the civil
rights movement when I came into the
South in the late 1950s there was no
sign really no really important sign of
of a great movement and it looked kind
of hopeless but people began to do
things people began is sitting in and
then their sit-in spread and people with
on the Freedom Rides and the idea spread
and the demonstrations took place in
this city in that city of another city
and soon the demonstrations were all
over the south and thousands of people
were being put in jail and the pictures
were now going out all over the world
and the administration was becoming
embarrassed this is very important to
embarrass the people in power even
though you know we have leaders who are
not easily embarrassed
yeah but that that that I think it is
one answer to the question and that is
to show the history of those times when
people have felt helpless or at the
beginning of the Vietnam War and I
remember this very distinctly 1960
spring 65 beginning of the escalation of
the war we had a demonstration on the
Boston Common against the war one
hundred people showed up in a few years
later
well October 69 actually another
anti-war meeting on the Boston Common a
hundred thousand people were there the
movement grew it grew and grew as people
didn't give up people persisted and
people understood that all movement
starts small and all movements starts
with a kind of hopelessness and the
feeling you know what are we doing but
if people persist and persist and
persist there's a chance that something
may happen the other the other thing I
said there were two right so shouldn't
we get the second very often this
happens in class you say I will now tell
you the five causes of the American
Revolution after number three the
teacher falters but I can met I can
remember two that's as high as I go and
the the second point is to overcome
cynicism and the feeling of helplessness
surround yourself with active people
people who are doing things when people
don't do anything it's very easy to get
hopeless when people are acting even if
the action doesn't seem to bring
anything immediate but after all there's
something about resisting the
authorities there's something about
speaking your mind about being honest
about what you're doing even if you
don't see any immediate results
something about that which is very
satisfying and vigor ating and it
invigorates other people too
my question has to do with your tonight
you brought up civil disobedience and
the lack I guess of it now and what
makes me curious is why is that and I
just wanted there's people like Aaron
Russo who's a filmmaker who's got a
movie out America freedom to fascism and
they're calling people big people like
that are calling for civil disobedience
but I think there's a lack of civil
disobedience because of things like the
Patriot Act people are scared to you
know do that stuff as they weren't back
in the 60s but is there a connection
between you know that and the lack of
people doing that kind of stuff today
and also the the truth movement for 9/11
is there the project for a new American
Century I'm sure you're familiar with
that and I'm wondering if they had a
plan and do you think there was this
plan before 9/11 happened and a
connection do you have any feelings on
the 9/11 truth movement you all know
about a 9/11 truth movement no it's it's
I thought there people tell me if I'm
misrepresenting which I do but people
very often repeat the questions that
they want to hear not the questions that
were actually asked so but the truth
9/11 truth movement I think is a
movement which is very suspicious of
what happened on 9/11 suspicious of the
official story and they think that maybe
there's another story and I think it may
be the administration that is hiding
something serious well I don't thank Lee
I don't know you know
I don't know those secrets I swear I
don't ah you say and I'll just say this
about 9/11 the the administration has
used 9/11 has used it to scare people
and to do what it wanted what I wanted
was to move troops into the Middle East
where the oil is he wanted to set up
military bases in the Middle East and it
used the 9/11 as a wonderful opportunity
it wasn't it wasn't going to do anything
about terrorism it's very obvious now to
simply follow the events of 9/11 by
bombing Afghanistan did not reduce
terrorism in fact it increased the
possibility of terrorism we have by our
actions in the Middle East since 9/11
largely increase the number of
terrorists in the Middle East and in the
world because we haven't agonized so
many people when you bomb people you
antagonize them when you invade people
you antagonize them you make enemies you
get people angry and out of the anger of
millions of people a small number of
them may become terrorists so they've
used 9/11 to me that's the important
truth about 9/11 the last figure I've
mentioned the Patriot Act yes I in the
past couple of weeks the Bush
administration has fired ten or more top
attorneys in the Justice Department and
under a secret provision of the Patriot
Act has been replacing them without
congressional approval and with
basically no oversight
so my question about that is you
mentioned that we should bring people
who are bringing people to justice food
basically impeachment and such things
what happens is that if the leak when
the legal system is no longer responsive
or refuses to take action or is filled
with figureheads that will not act what
can we do then if the actual institution
does no long no longer can deliver that
justice that is necessary and needed
that's a that's a really important
question because it
represents reality as the reality is
that the system of justice is no longer
if it ever was really something you
could turn to to be sure that that the
justice system would protect you and
protect your rights this is this has
only rarely been true in American
history the justice system has been like
other parts of the government and
generally beholden to too powerful
interests and now worse than ever and
now the Bush administration has taken
total hold of the system of justice and
it's using all the federal court
appointees on the district court level
and the appeals court level it has the
Supreme Court in its hands of partly
with the collaboration of the Democratic
Party which caves in instead of fighting
the Republican nominees and so yes what
do you do when you can't depend on a
system of justice to redress your
grievances
that's where civil disobedience comes in
that's where popular action comes in and
that's where you go over the heads of
the courts that you appeal to your
elected representatives since the people
in the Justice Department are not
elected they've not beholdin to anybody
they often have lifetime jobs your
representatives at least have some
commitment to represent a constituencies
and that's why the the putting pressure
on your representatives to be in holding
impeachment hearings and to demand
cutting off funds for the war and
bringing the troops back as fast as
possible I think that's the way
bypassing a recalcitrant and reactionary
justice system the u.s. does seem to
abuse the fear of terrorism really well
and yet the hypocrisy of the of the
current government around defending the
terrorists who have been attacking Cuba
by putting the Cuban five in jail for
having exposed what they were doing
seems like a lesson that people really
need to hear about in this country and
yet there's been such silence and I'm
I'm wondering if you could say a little
bit I know wrote a wonderful chapter in
a book super power principles kind of on
the background of us-cuba relations but
I'm realizing a lot of people don't know
about these five guys locked up yeah oh
yeah yeah that's one of those things
that have happened that nobody ever
hears about and people are locked away
and these they've been locked away for
years and they're 5 Cubans right you
correct me if I'm wrong about any of
these facts because you obviously know
and you say usually the questioner knows
more than the reply err and that so you
but my recollection these are five
Cubans who who infiltrated the sort of
the anti-castro Network in Miami because
a terrorist acts will being committed
against Cuba they have been in fact ever
since Castro took power it's not a
secret that the United States tried to
invade Cuba the United States tried to
assassinate Castro that the United
States yeah was engaged in secret
terrorist activities against Cuba and so
these five Cubans tried to find out
about that and they were arrested
charged with terrorism held I think for
a long time without right to counsel
without the right to see their families
and they're still in prison right after
years and so there are these things that
go on that so many of them that you
never hear about in the press of course
you cannot really depend on a major
media to report on these things so we
depend on people like you to get it
before the microphone and to tell people
about it
some postcards in the in the back table
if people want to send just notices to
their Congress people there's
information on them and then they can
sign them and send them off to Congress
because it is it's just so egregious but
thank you greetings um my question it's
more like looking for your input looking
at George Bush in the way he got into
office I see the large part of that came
from the backing of fundamentalist
religious groups and that their strong
desire was to impose their religious
beliefs on the legislative process so
that they could change the laws of the
country so that whatever their religious
beliefs are that would be what the laws
of the country were and I'm just curious
as to what your thoughts are on you know
the whole role that fundamentalist
religion had to do with putting Bush in
power well you know we never really had
a separation of church and state in this
country no matter you know that they
talk about it as a principle of American
democracy it's never been real I mean
the presidents I've always taken notes
on the Bible the God has always been
invoked all the time any president who
wanted to invade any country has said
God told him to do that you know because
God studies the map and decides where we
will invade and then Bush goes it's just
the bush has gone farther than anybody
else in tying this administration to in
this case fundamentalist radical fanatic
Christianity there's a different
Christianity there's a Christianity
which is not fundamentalist there's a
Christianity which is not extremists and
fanatic there's a Christianity which is
humanist and I mean look at the the
Catholic anti-war people you know look
at the the church men who have supported
social movements so you know
Christianity can be used for good or for
ill and Bush has used it and
fundamentalist churches have been so
closely tied to him as to give him great
great support
and and I think that fortunately they do
not command the support of the majority
of Christians in this country you know
now maybe they have 20% on a twenty five
percent but there's always been well I
shouldn't say always that's an extreme
statement but I'm not an extremist ah
there that had been for a long time a
fundamental core of immovable right-wing
sentiment in this country which probably
accounts for twenty-five or thirty
percent of the population and there's
probably a little you can do to move
them the problem is to move everybody
else and when you move enough other
people who are not who are not
transfixed by by this pseudo religious
idea that God is on the side of imperial
power and say then you know it's
possible for religion to play a positive
role I have one comment and one question
I'm a combat veteran who was abused by
his own people while serving the
military and a lot of us who face
similar things tried to go to our
congressmen and Senators and they've
refused to meet with us we've also gone
to the press and they refused to air
what we have to say which brings me to
the question do you have any advice on
other ways to get things public
we pride rallies and that so far hasn't
worked a lot either to get things
published by our public meaning called
publicize how to make the congressman
meet the whole bit abuse yeah you know
what what happened during the Vietnam
War when when congressmen refused to
meet with people of the people who tried
to meet with these congressmen sat in
their offices they went to see them and
they wouldn't leave that's an act of
civil disobedience ah and that brought
attention and that sometimes embarrassed
the congressmen into finally meeting
with them but yet when the Orthodox
channels don't respond then you have to
go outside the Orthodox
channels the Orthodox channels do not
fulfill the requirements of democracy so
yeah there are things that can be done
they're hard they required they take
risks you know maybe very well maybe
arrested and so on but in times of
crisis that's what people do people did
that in the South during the movement
their people did that during the Vietnam
War during the 80s when Reagan was
carrying on covert warfare in Nicaragua
and Honduras in El Salvador are people
committed civil disobedience at one
point 500 of us sat it in the JFK
building here in Boston and wouldn't
move when the building closed down they
arrested 500 of us the charge was based
on an old statute you know and was
abbreviated as the old statute was like
failure to quit the premises you see and
it was abbreviated as failure to quit
and that's what we have to do we have to
fail to quit yeah
a quick question and then longer
question or two this is driving me nuts
I've been an admirer of you for over
thirty years so you want to drive me
nuts
I'll try I'm older than many of the
people here thirty years ago when I was
in school we read a book by you I can't
remember the name of it about Vietnam I
don't believe it's Vietnam I'm logic
it's another book and I'd like a read as
a paperback was a dread in it and I was
trying to look for it today it's driving
me nuts I can't remember the name of it
because I hope I neither can i I know
it's written by you though sure my
second question question is if I
understood you correctly you were
mentioning that government is sort of
for the wealthy in the upper on the
other hand I've heard nothing I'm
disputing you people like Ted Kennedy
and maybe Michael Dukakis and others
being ones that have been sort of there
to help the underdog the immigrants some
a they don't money giving out free you
know food stamps a free freeway to those
people do you agree with that or
disagree with that
remove the fact that Kennedy and some of
those other people are sort of on the
other end of what you were saying where
the government serves Oh rich rather
than happy and thirdly who do you see is
a good president for the nursery I only
heard one yeah you're skipping one okay
the book was the other one oh the book
oh I see who do you like to see be our
next president who would I like to see
on next no decision and the comment
about the Kennedy
I just soon have a lottery and choose
somebody from this audience and
and I would I would gamble did anybody
in this audience would probably do a
better job than whoever is going to be
selected by the Democratic Party so I'm
half serious but but to give your
question about know what about Kennedy
and Dukakis and so on doing good things
for the poor well yeah there are
congressmen who are better than other
congressmen the congressman or more
liberal and the congressmen who have a
better idea of what our tax structure
should be and so on and it's nice to
have those congressmen we should
encourage them and support them and and
but they always need to be encouraged
they always need to be pushed and they
are our distinct minority in our system
of representation so as for who I would
like to see president unfortunately it's
very hard to find somebody who in the
high reaches of the Democratic Party
when I look at the possible candidates
well process of elimination right
Hillary Clinton no Biden nope
Obama mmm possibly
John Edwards hmm possibly but you're
putting me in that position you see the
position that we're always in at
election time where we don't find
anybody who really represents up use we
try to find somebody who a little bit
represents of use you see Ralph Nader
would represent my views and Ralph Nader
you see but the political system won't
give him a chance
you know it's a sad thing we we talk
about bringing democracy to other
countries say oh they're having an
election this means democracy so we have
elections all the time doesn't mean
democracy and now you have two parties
and they choose you know a or a prime
you say and that's it yes I don't serve
what do you think about God what do you
think about government and uh and mental
health what do I think about government
and mental health yes whoo ah I don't
know I mean what can I say but I think
the government should do more in the
area of mental health yes I mean you
know I think the government should do
much more in the way of health leaving
health and leaving mental health to
private enterprise is not conducive to
giving people the best medical care
whether it's in physical health or
mental health so yeah I think would be
important for a universal health care
system where people who have problems in
mental health can take care of those
problems without spending a lot of money
and where you know that kind of help is
available to them and the government can
be a kind of intermediary for that
process I don't know what else to say
I don't know that much you know well the
the government seems to overtake on
funding
grants for mental health seems so every
year it seems to do what every year or
so I I've noticed through candidates
being elected governor or through the
fights just like gay and lesbian rights
they seem to battle back and forth and
whether they give or take the the rights
it seems like we're always economically
fighting for them so it's a give or take
war economics wise as well as a
politically standing wise for our
numbers of candidates who are again
against are positive and it seems like
the deciding vote always comes up to the
one standing in power arm I think that
when they my own political view is that
if they were to take away the rights
where they'd already been initiated that
they were benefit of mankind why take
them back well right to do so on over
shorten our notice well as all I can say
is you I think you should find people
who agree with you about the mental
health situation and organize and
campaign for what you believe in we near
the end of our rope I mean at the end of
my rope ah and yeah who are my handlers
here Alex what is our situation with
time one more question in will do book
signing okay good evening hi I'm a
second semester senior here at Brandeis
which means I'll be graduating this may
but the past four years I've been taking
courses and justice and liberty and
doing case studies on developing nations
being taken advantage of by
multinational corporations and writing
papers about the
you know the dominating power of money
interest in this and that but now it's
time to graduate and get a job and those
things are all well and good from behind
my desk in my room but when I look at my
job options for next year
realistically a lot of things I'm
looking at our consulting firms or jobs
in the financial world and I know a lot
of friends also who are more politically
liberal you know we're taking jobs in
investment banking and feels like this
not necessarily firms that have you know
dirty records human rights wise or Seng
like this but certainly part of you know
part of a what you're talking about
so some like me who's more on the fence
you know I think I'm stuck in an ethical
dilemma I'm not exactly sure you know
where one goes in the situation so I
don't know if you have two minutes to
talk me out of working for corporate
America though would you say okay two
minutes to solve your problem
actually we all face that problem we
have to we have to make a living and we
want to do something good in the world
and we have to find ways of doing it
sometimes you can make a living and in
the way you make your living you could
do something good in the world if you're
only a small number of people are lucky
enough to be able to do that no you work
for a nonprofit corporation you know
work for Amnesty International work or
at work for a progressive magazine etc
etc right good stuff and get published
and that's sort of they some of us are
lucky and we can do that most people
cannot and so what what most people do
the Hat you make a living in whatever
way you can so long as you don't kill
people and exploit people the fiendishly
and but you make a living in whatever
way you can
but carve out part of your life and part
of your time to be a citizen of the
nation and of the world but it's it's
harder you have to do two things you
know it's like a woman who has to take
care of kids and and do a job at the
same time all of us have to do two
things at once and that's the reality of
it thank